seine neue dramatische entwicklung im
fall des putin kritikers alexej nawalny
der vergiftet worden sein soll
heute nacht um kurz nach drei startete
in nürnberg ein rettungsflieger um eine
weile hier zu uns nach deutschland zu
holen damit er hier behandelt werden
kann
doch nun wollen die russischen ärzte dem
transport nicht zustimme nach
bild-informationen die offizielle
begründung navalny sei nicht
transportfähig er liegt noch immer im
koma
seine sprecherin schrieb bei twitter das
transportverbot bedeutet eine direkte
bedrohung für sein leben in der
gegenwärtigen situation ohne ausrüstung
und ohne diagnose zu bleiben dem
krankenhaus zu bleiben sei tödlich und
dabei möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
meinem kollegen viele patov jetzt im
studio philipp was ist der aktuelle
stand wo befindet sich nach einer jetzt
gerade weil nähe befindet sich immer
noch auf der intensivstation im
krankenhaus in omsk und das ist gleich
aus zwei gründen sehr problematisch das
sagen zumindest die mitarbeiter und auch
die ehefrau von navalny zum einen sagen
sie dass das krankenhaus nicht genug
nicht gut genug ausgerüstet ist
um einen so schweren fall zu behandeln
und zum zweiten geht es ihnen natürlich
um die aufklärung sie wollen wissen
welcher giftstoff befindet sich noch im
körper von navalny und dann natürlich
auch die frage wer könnte diesen
giftstoff in sein körper gebracht haben
sprich wer hat ihn vergiftet und sie
glauben nicht daran dass diese
aufklärung gewährleistet kann von den
russischen ärzten und von der russischen
polizei die sich natürlich auch schon im
krankenhaus befindet und heute morgen
gab es dazu auch ein gespräch zwischen
ärzten zwischen behörden und
mitarbeitern von navalny es wurde
bestätigt dass ein giftstoff in seinem
körper gefunden wurde
allerdings wird nicht kommuniziert und
welchen giftstoff es sich handelt und
die sprecherin von der wahlen die sagt
das nur weil die dringend ausreisen muss
am besten nach deutschland weil
ansonsten bald nicht mehr nachgewiesen
werden kann dass sich ein giftstoff
befindet also sagen wir mal dass navalny
erst in drei vier fünf tagen wenn er
werde erst dann in deutschland ankommt
dann könnte es womöglich schon zu spät
sein um nachzuweisen um welches gift es
sich handelt mit dem der wein vergiftet
wurde
kann man denn ungefähr abschätzen wie
lange die russischen ärzte jetzt ihn
noch in russland behalten wollen dann
sagen dass er nicht
hier werden kann ja also man muss ganz
klar sagen dass es keine entscheidung
die russische ärzte alleine treffen
solche entscheidung trifft in russland
eine einzige instanzen das ist der kreml
in moskau
der sprecher von putin herpes kauf hat
gestern angekündigt dass man eine
ausreise von derweil die nicht im wege
stehen werde
allerdings verzögert sie sich bislang es
kann natürlich sein dass es das klappt
um das zu beschleunigen haben sich die
mitarbeiter von reini an den
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte gewandt und fordern darin
dass der russischen regierung untersagt
wird die ausreise weiter zu verzögern
und zu verhindern
bald findet auch eine pressekonferenz
mit peres kopf statt der wird er
vermutlich wieder diese frage
beantworten müssen was denn jetzt mit
der ausreise ist der flieger ist heute
früh zwischen sieben und acht uhr früh
mesz gelandet also es ist alles bereit
man wartet nur noch auf die transport
bestätigung und sobald die kommt kann
den ball nicht ausgeflogen werden
das ist gerade schon gesagt wichtig
unter anderem um zu erfahren wo womit er
vergiftet worden ist aber die frage die
natürlich auch noch in einem raum von
wem
und jetzt wird auch spekuliert ob das
ganze vielleicht sogar was mit
weißrussland zu tun hat dort seit tagen
im wochenend demonstrationen wegen lukas
schenkel wegen seiner erneuten wahl
wie schätzt du die situation ein könnte
das wirklich ein ablenkungsmanöver
gewesen sein von russland ja also ich
möchte wirklich nicht spekulieren auch
wenn sich im netz natürlich diverse
spekulationen finden
das timing ist natürlich wahnsinnig
seltsam auch wenn es wenn das nur zufall
ist auch wenn das nicht so beabsichtigt
war aber navalny wurde ja auch und
weißrussischen
persönlich genannt und kritisiert er
wurde beschuldigt dass auch er hinter
den demonstrationen in weißrussland
steckt und dass neuwahlen jetzt
ausgerechnet in so einer internationalen
krise in die auch russland stark
verwickelt ist das ein weil ihn
ausgerechnet jetzt vergiftet wird dass
das wirkt einfach seltsam aber ich
glaube da sollte man von spekulationen
wirklich wirklich die die hände lassen
was man auf jeden fall sagen kann ist
dass das russische regime unter verdacht
steht eine weile vergiftet zu haben es
ist nicht der erste anschlag auf einen
oppositionellen und es ist auch nicht
der erste anschlag auf navalny selbst
und wenn man weiß was in russland mit
oppositionellen seit jahren und
jahrzehnten passiert zumindest seit
putin an der macht ist dann ist es klar
dass der erste verdächtige in moskau und
krimml sitzt ja genau deswegen wollen
wir uns jetzt einmal die chronik der
arbeit von alexei navalny bis jetzt
anschauen der 44 jährige gilt als einer
der größten kritiker des kreml und damit
natürlich auch von wladimir putin
er ist investigativer journalist
rechtsanwalt und oppositioneller
politiker alexej nawalny steht für all
das was nach 20 jahren putin von der
zarten demokratie der 90er jahre in
russland übrig geblieben ist
jetzt liegt navalny im koma nachdem er
am flughafen der sibirischen stadt tomsk
einen möglicherweise vergifteten tee
getrunken hat seine kollegen machen
putins creme für den mutmaßlichen
anschlag verantwortlich
wladimir putin ließ ihn schon mehr als
20 mal ins gefängnis sperren und krimml
freundliche extremisten versuchten ihn
sogar zu töten
navalny ist ein ungebrochener kritiker
des systems hat es auf das wichtigste
abgesehen dass das system am laufen hält
korruption und er hat es gewagt
machtambitionen zu formulieren damit ist
er für alle am system beteiligten ein
natürlicher gegner die anzeichen dafür
dass navalny vergiftet wurde lassen die
handschrift und methodik des russischen
regimes im umgang mit kritikern vermuten
dass moskau nicht davor zurückschreckt
kritiker brutal aus dem weg zu räumen
das ist allerdings nicht neu wir nun aus
berlin zugeschaltet jack abidi
filmproduzent und organisator von cinema
for peace
wie sie haben den flug organisiert der
eigentlich jetzt zurück nach deutschland
gehen sollte nun halten die russischen
ärzte diesen auf was denken sie steckt
dahinter
schwer zu sagen es war gestern alles
selber waschen muss so sehr schnell
organisiert werden aber wir haben es
dann bis nach mitternacht hin bekommen
alle papiere zu haben
und nachdem ihr auch dann vermerken und
matt raum beziehungsweise auch peskow im
kreml grünes licht signalisiert haben
dass eine aufnahme möglich ist gehen wir
eigentlich davon aus dass das glatt
gehen könnte
der flieger sollte morgen um 18 1
gelandet aber leider kam die nachricht
dass es bei einer sitzung der ärzte zu
der auffassung kam dass er nicht
reisefähig ist
während eigentlich eigene leute von
navalny auch ärzte die eingeflogen sind
aus moskau beziehungsweise seine ehefrau
der meinung waren dass er weise fähig
ist es so schnell wie möglich eigentlich
raus geflogen werden sollte
dazu muss man sagen der flieger der aus
nürnberg gestartet ist hatte natürlich
auch medizinisches personal an bord
richtig
ja dieses personal ist momentan vor ort
auf dem flieger zum spezialisten
untermann arzt ein rettungssanitäter
eine krankenschwester die
spezialisierung auf solche schweren
fälle nahm auch leute die sich im koma
befindet die nicht bei bewusstsein sind
trotzdem sicher zu transportieren und
letztendlich haben wir jetzt den
vorschlag gemacht dass diese dieses mit
sicher personal was mit dem flugzeug
dort vor ort ist dass es einen das
gewährt bekommt zu navalny ihn selber zu
untersuchen
denn letztendlich villen sind auch von
sich aus nicht transportieren wenn sie
der meinung waren dass es zu
lebensgefährlich werde
also insofern ist seine zweite second
unabhängige optimieren glaube ich genau
das richtige
und wir haben jetzt unter anderem aus
australien haben das kanzleramt gebeten
doch auf die diplomatischen wege im
kreml zu sprechen
das ist doch möglich ist dass das
medizinische personal was aus
deutschland eingeflogen ist auch den
patienten begutachten darf sollte dieser
vorschlag abgelehnt werden können sie
sich vorstellen dass das alles jetzt
dafür getan wird damit man in einigen
tagen nicht mehr nachweisen kann
wo mittlerweile vergiftet worden ist
das ist die vermutung von peter wehr
siller von putz den wir vor zwei jahren
in einem ähnlichen fall eingeflogen
haben vor dem hintergrund dass wir mit
pussy etwas zu nummer profis einige
projekte zusammen gemacht hatten und
deren filme ausgezeichnet hatten
und peter hat mich gestern kontaktiert
ebenso wie naturliebhaber von privat und
haben gesagt das war ein guter freund
ist ob wir das gleiche machen könnten so
insofern ist das entstanden und peter
ist ganz bei der sache dabei kommentiert
die ganzen vorgänger und seine erste
vermutete in der tat die sache so lange
herauszuzögern um dann nicht mehr
feststellen zu können mit welchen stoff
tatsächlich der wahl nicht vergiftet
worden ist ich hatte es bereits erwähnt
sie haben diesen rettungsflieger die
ganze rettungsaktion organisiert alles
musste sehr schnell gehen
wie genau hat das überhaupt funktioniert
das dann heute nacht bereits der flieger
aus nürnberg starten konnte und wer
zahlt dafür
wir haben private freunde förderer die
das bezahlen also es bezahlt ist wieder
eine stiftung noch die öffentliche hand
der steuerzahler muss dafür nicht
aufkommen sie können sich nicht
vollständig relativ teuer ist auf die
schnelle
solch ein spezielles medizinisches
flugzeug zu bekommen im fach personal da
war noch viele andere ihn jetzt zu
klären mit corona test mit mit
fluggenehmigungen lande genehme und so
weiter und so fort
ja also bis bis nachts um 08 35 haben
wir gekämpft alles zusammen zu bekommen
hatten nur noch den das aufnahme
schreiben der charité bekommen das ist
eine art und 23 uhr also quasi es war
eine nacht und nebel aktion quasi und
wir haben auch die ganze nacht
durchgearbeitet den flug begleitet kann
man heutzutage ja mit modernen apps
haben den flug mit verfolgt zwar in den
diskussionen vor ort ins gesäß vier
stunden später also dort sind alle schon
seit dort morgen um vier uhr morgens im
einsatz
also wir waren jetzt alle rund um die
uhr beschäftigt denken sie dass heute
der flieger noch zurückkehren kann dass
sich diese probleme mit dem ärzten in
russland so schnell klären
die devise momentan ist dass der flieger
nicht zurück fliegt ohne navalny
mit dabei zu haben aber letztendlich
nachdem das ganze bisherige humanitäre
angelegenheit für uns gewesen ist wird
es nun doch immer mehr zu einer
politischen und da muss wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch die politik mit einer
miteinander sprechen
vielen dank für dieses gespräch
dankeschön und nun möchte ich sprechen
mit einem langjährigen freund von nah
wie nie
sergey lagodinsky ist mir nun
zugeschaltet sie kennen ihn schon sehr
lange was waren ihre ersten gedanken als
sie von der nachricht der vergiftung
gehört haben und auch die ersten videos
und bilder gesehen haben
hallo schon morgen
es tut natürlich weh diese nachrichten
und diese bilder zu sehen aber
andererseits alle die die lage in
russland einerseits und die arbeit von
canon sind leider wenig überrascht das
ist ja nicht das erste mal dass sein
leben und seine körperliche
unversehrtheit die zielscheibe sind und
insofern war das also es ist wirklich
schwer das auszusprechen aber für mich
war das nur eine frage der zeit bis
wieder der versuch gestartet wird in aus
dem weg zu räumen
was macht man bei nie für sie aus sowohl
als mensch als auch als kreml kritiker
in der opposition
schauen sie also ich bin abgeordnete im
europäischen parlament wie die grünen
und ich kenne alexy schon seit mehr als
zehn jahren
wir sind nicht uns in allen punkten
immer einverstanden
alexei kommt aus einem kontext wo ihnen
die politischen diskurse etwas anders
gelagert sind als bei uns aber du mich
war das immer ein mensch der für seine
sache brennt denn nicht selber
korrumpierbar ist der absolut
unglaublich fleißig ist und weil sie bei
der sache immer dabei ist also ich
erinner mich das erzähle ich immer
wieder erinnere mich an unsere zeit in
ihr an der yale university in den pausen
wo wir alle dann quasi uns unterhalten
haben und die freizeit genossen haben
saß er ehemals schon damals am computer
und versuchte eben dieses netzwerk diese
organisation aufzubauen oder zu fördern
also jemand der menschlich absolut in
ordnung ist wird man das auf
berlinerisch sagen würde und der auch
professionell und von seiner art politik
zu machen wirklich ein großes asset ist
und eine wirklich spezielle erscheinung
für die russische politische szene
das ist jemand der eine ausnahme talent
und ein ausnahme mensch ist in russland
sie haben gerade gesagt dass man leider
fast sagen muss es war nur eine frage
der zeit dieser giftanschlag ist nicht
der erste der in russland passiert ist
vor allem auf oppositionelle ist eine
opposition in russland überhaupt
wirklich möglich
opposition ist immer möglich
ja das lässt sich natürlich so leicht
ihre berliner der russe sitzt aber wenn
wir viele verschiedene länder sehen
es ist immer möglich etwas das sehen wir
auch in belarus ja gerade gegen das
system zu machen die frage ist immer da
ist die frage des risikos und das ist
anna wahlen
das besondere das er dass ihm dieses
risiko immer bewusst war
also ich habe ihn ja auch um viele haben
den immer wieder gefragt er wusste ist
er wusste auch dass er ständig
beschattet wird oder weiß ist ich hoffe
dass das alles gut geht gesundheitlich
am ende er weiß dass ihm hinterher immer
auch im ausland special forces hgb was
auch immer
immer dabei sind und ihm beobachten und
trotzdem macht er diese arbeit und das
ist für mich ein bild für einen
oppositionellen politiker dem wir alle
nur dass wir alle nur bewundern können
ja gerade diejenigen die in sicheren
demokratischen systemen und kontexten
arbeiten wir können uns gar nicht
vorstellen was für ein leben es bedeutet
in ländern wie in russland so eine tolle
arbeit zu machen gerade in puncto anti
korruption
ja man kann ja viele sachen sagen und
aufrufen aber da wo es um macht
einerseits und geld andererseits geht
und beides hat mehr herausgefordert in
russland auch übrigens mit seinem system
der smarten wahlen das ist ja ein system
was er ausgedacht hat und in lokalen war
ein wirklich großer gefahr ist für die
regierenden regierende partei einiges
russland in diesen beiden punkten bis du
dich sagen in russland fast schon
vogelfrei wenn es um geld geht um und um
macht
sie haben gerade auch einmal
weißrussland angesprochen denken sie es
könnte einen zusammenhang geben jetzt
zwischen diesen giftanschlag auf hawaii
nie und der jetzigen situation in
weißrussland
ja also wie ihr kollege vielleicht ja
schon sagte ich ich würde da ungerne
spekulieren ehrlich gesagt ich würde
diese wahrscheinlichkeit als niedrig
schätzen es ist aber klar dass dann
politisch gesehen ja und und fast schon
zu sagen demokratie philosophisch
gesehen ist es ein zusammenkommen von
diesen beiden ereignissen was zeigt was
es geht ja und was auch dem was
sozusagen auf der rechnung steht in
dieser ganzen situation und was was mir
auch wichtig ist
das merke ich an mir ich habe ja die
situation in belarus sehr genau verfolgt
und plötzlich kommt eben dieses andere
ereignis und die ganze öffentliche und
politische aufmerksamkeit ist umgelenkt
und die politische energie ist umgelenkt
und darauf konzentriert das leben um
diesen menschen zu retten und auch zu
recht wird dürfen aber nicht es erlauben
dass wir die situation in belarus aus
den augen aus dem blickfeld lassen es
ist weiterhin dort sehr prekär und der
kampf denn die wähler russen führen ist
ja der selber kam der alten denn auch
navalny für das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen also müssen beides weiterhin
leidenschaftlich begleiten und das hoffe
ich auch und übrigens rufe ich dazu auf
dass die brüsseler politiker borel von
von der leyen sich nicht nur öffentlich
äußern sondern auch eher im hintergrund
diplomatischen druck auf die russische
regierung ausüben dass er war
ausgelassen wird das ist ungemein
wichtig weil das entscheidend sich die
ärzte vor ort dafür kennen wir russland
zu sehr das ist eine entscheidung die
ganz oben getroffen wurde
vielen dank sergey lagodinsky für ihre
einblicke vor allem in das leben von
avni dankeschön
wir haben es jetzt immer wieder gehört
solche giftanschläge sind in russland
jetzt nicht zum ersten mal passiert
deswegen wollen wir uns noch einmal die
chronik dieser gift fälle anschauen
alexej nawalny ist einer der schärfsten
kritiker der russischen führung
er wurde in der vergangenheit
festgenommen und es gab bereits mehrere
anschläge auf ihn
nun liegt der oppositionelle im koma
kurz vor den russischen kommunalwahlen
im september
in sibirien hat navalny vor einem flug
eine tasse tee an einem flughafen
getrunken
im flugzeug ist der 44-jährige dann
ohnmächtig geworden
er kam in ein sibirisches krankenhaus
der oppositionelle war in der region
wegen einer recherche unterwegs eine
reisebegleiterin und unter anderem auch
ein anwalt einer wahl ließ sprechen von
einer vergiftung die ärzte wollen das
nicht ausschließen
in russland sind mutmaßliche
vergiftungen im politischen milieu in
der vergangenheit immer wieder ein thema
2018 wurde der geheimagent sergej
skripal und seine tochter in england mit
dem nervengift novy job beinahe getötet
ebenfalls 2018 verdächtigt ein mitglied
der politik punkgruppe passiert den
russischen geheimdienst ihn vergiftet zu
haben
2006 erkrankte der russische ex spion
alexander litvinenko seine haare fallen
ihm aus er wird immer schwächer und
stirbt an einer hohen dosis polonium 210
2004 gibt es einen dioxin anschlag auf
den späteren ukrainischen präsidenten
viktor juschtschenko und auch navalny
wurde nach eigenen angaben bereits
vergiftet als er in russland eine
haftstrafe absitzen musste und nun
möchte sprechen mit dr gerd schönfelder
von der berliner charité
herr dr schönfelder sie sind toxikologe
wir haben gerade gehört dabei nie wird
momentan nicht von den russischen ärzten
nach deutschland gelassen und die
befürchtung ist nun dass man dann dem
nächsten nicht mehr nachweisen kann
womit er vergiftet worden ist wie viel
zeit ist in solchen fällen ja diese
aussage kann man so jetzt gar nicht
treffen
das hängt sehr stark davon ab was
tatsächlich die grundlage ist für diese
art von erkrankungen
es werden ja wilde spekulationen
durchgeführt ob es sich hierbei um eine
potentielle intoxikation handelt und je
nachdem wenn es tatsächlich um eine
solche talks intoxikation sich handeln
sollte dann kommt das sehr stark auf das
sogenannte gift an wie lange es sich im
körper nachweisen lässt das ist
natürlich zum einen möglich indem man
direkt den stoff nachweis
wir haben aber auch die möglichkeiten
indirekt diese stoffe nachzuweisen in
dem sich durch veränderungen im körper
entweder sogenannte metaboliten bilden
oder abbauprodukte von organen die man
dann als indirekten nachweis führen kann
heißt wenn er erst in ein paar tagen
nach deutschland kann besteht noch immer
die möglichkeit nachzuweisen woran womit
er vergiftet worden ist nur wenn dieses
gift oder seine abbauprodukte oder
indirekte nachweis methoden die es dann
noch ermöglichen oder in bestimmten
tieferen körper kompartimenten geräten
dann nicht mehr nur von urin sondern
auch von anderen körperorgane
gewebeproben das nachweisbar ist das
kommt je nachdem auf die letztendlich
vergiftung an wenn es sich und ich
möchte dass dann wenn es sich wirklich
um eine vergiftung handelte wir wissen
ja noch gar nichts dazu genau fängt man
dann an um das dann zu beweisen was
macht man mit dem patient in diesem fall
navalny um dann zu sehen ob er vergiftet
worden ist und wenn ja an mit was ja das
ist ein ganz normales standard prozedere
wie wir dort vorgehen
zum einen steht immer im vordergrund
erst mal die sicherung des lebens und
damit letztendlich der lebenswichtigen
organe und das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt
auch gerade in russland durchgeführt
es scheint so zu sein dass er in der
jetzigen situation nicht transportfähig
ist zumindest nicht mit dem flugzeug
unter spricht dafür dass er in einem
doch sehr angespannten körperlichen
zustand und gesundheitlichen zustand
sich befindet die konsequenz ist wenn er
dann hier her käme also werden wir in
deutschland landen würde
und an ärzte übergeben wird dann werden
diese erst einmal klassischerweise die
symptome lage aufnehmen und anhand
dieser symptom lage das anhand des
klinischen krankheitsbildes darstellen
und identifizieren um welche
potenziellen ereignisse es sich
gehandelt hat die möglicherweise mit
dieser erkrankungen im zusammenhang
stehen was dann passiert es letztendlich
wiederum eine intensivmedizinische
behandlung eine sicherung des lebens und
dann fängt es endlich dieses archer
chrome spiel an dass man versucht anhand
der einzelnen symptome eine sogenannte
differentialdiagnose durchzuführen und
diese dann mit hilfe von labordiagnostik
zu unterstützen
dies kann mehrere tage dauern hängt sehr
stark davon ab wie sich das
krankheitsbild darstellt oft sind sehen
wir überlagerungen von verschiedenen
krankheitsbildern das macht es meist
schwieriger und es bleibt dann den
ärzten erst einmal nur übrig die
akutsituationen zu sichern
und wie gesagt den sherlock holmes zu
spielen um dann herauszufinden um was es
sich dann tatsächlich handelt was zu
dieser art von erkrankung geführt hat
vielen dank herr top der schönfelder für
diese erklärung dankeschön über den
pfeilen derweilen die möchte ich nun
auch noch sprechen mit dem
außenpolitischen sprecher der fdp mir
nun zugeschaltet raserei
guten morgen wir haben jetzt schon
gehört die bundeskanzlerin und
frankreichs präsident markus fordern
eine aufklärung dieses falls dieser
vergiftung kann man das von den
russischen behörden wirklich erwarten
guten morgen
ich glaube nicht ich glaube dass die
russischen behörden in diesem fall nicht
mit deutschen behörden oder
französischen behörden oder andere
zusammenarbeiten werden russland hat in
diesem fall das ist meine derzeitige
einschätzung kein interesse daran dass
dieser sachverhalt aufgeklärt wird und
ich gehe in dieser situation ich bin
tief besorgt selbstverständlich über den
gesundheitszustand von navalny ich bin
aber auch besorgt über andere wo sicher
oppositionspolitiker und ich möchte an
dieser stelle auch betonen dass ich sehr
deutlich ein zusammenhang zu den
ereignissen in weißrussland weg denn das
was gerade in russland passiert ist
möglicherweise die vorbereitung auf
mögliche unruhen mögliche
demonstrationen auch in russland und dem
entsprechenden wert man versuchen im
vorfeld führende köpfe der opposition
auszuschalten oder zumindest aus dem weg
zu räumen
das ist aus meiner sicht eine da ist
eine methodik eine handschrift erkennbar
die außerordentlich besorgniserregend
eine handschrift wir haben gerade schon
darüber gesprochen dass solche
giftanschläge in russland leider keine
seltenheit sind was kann beispielsweise
deutschland tun um die opposition in
russland zu stärken um sie auch zu
schützen
naja das fängt das fängt bei belarus an
dass die bundesregierung aber auch die
europäische union ganz klar die gewalt
verurteilt aber nicht nur kommentiert
und spricht sondern sich auch wirklich
ganz deutlich mit demokratiebewegung mit
den demonstranten mit der
freiheitsbewegung dort solidarisiert und
das wird auch für russland gelten
russland weiß ganz genau
und das übrigens so waren die ereignisse
der letzten jahre russland hat im grunde
genau gemacht was die führung dort für
richtig gehalten hat und die europäer
war auch die bundesregierung wir waren
im grunde genommen wir haben alle dabei
nur das zu kommentieren konkrete
handlungen hat es in der vergangenheit
nicht gegeben und ich höre sogar immer
wieder deutsche politiker übrigens auch
deutsche journalisten die sagen man
müsse auf russland zu gehen
das sehe ich im moment nicht das wird er
als schwäche gesehen werden sondern man
braucht aus meiner sicht eine
man braucht selbstverständlich einen
dialog aber ganz konkrete und in solchen
fällen auch ganz konkrete personen
bezogenen sanktionen und diplomatischen
druck ganz klar gegenüber russland dass
so etwas nicht geduldet wird
das heißt sie fordern von der
bundesregierung wenn sich jetzt
herausstellt dass er tatsächlich
vergiftet worden ist konkrete sanktionen
gegen menschen in russland vielleicht
sogar gegen den kreml selber
selbstverständlich dass wird das wird
sich nicht vermeiden lassen und ich habe
ja bereits darauf hingewiesen es gibt
tatsächlich auch menschen in deutschland
politiker und journalisten die fordern
im zusammenhang mit der diskussion um
das immer sanktionen dass diese sogar
abgebaut werden soll
ich halte das für einen großen fehler
und das ist ja wir reden ja heute über
einen besonderen fall aber wir haben
unfassbar viele baustellen die derzeit
muss zusammenhang stehen mit russland
wieder sei es im nahen osten in syrien
in libyen sei es in der ukraine
und übrigens über cyberangriffe oder
andere dinge haben wir gar nicht
gesprochen
wir haben nächstes jahr eine
bundestagswahl ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass russland oder russische
kräfte oder der russische geheimdienst
oder wer auch immer besuchen werden
diese wahlen stören abläufe zu stören
das sind dinge die meine irgendwann mal
muss noch eine reaktion folgen also dem
westen sein dass ein staat der massen
die die sicherheit und stabilität im
grunde genommen weltweit gefährdet und
das wird von anderen nur diplomatisch
kommentiert auf dauer wird das so nicht
funktionieren
dementsprechend muss auch müssten auch
ganz klare gegenreaktionen folgen und
übrigens in vielen fällen in vielen
fällen ist es sogar nach einer gewissen
zeit erkennbar wer die auftraggeber sind
und wenn man diese auftraggeber kennt
wenn man weiß woher diese dinge steffen
dann muss man dementsprechend auch ganz
klar mit personenbezogene sanktionen mit
sehr konkreten harten sanktionen auch
gegen einzelne personen die dort
involviert sind auch vorgehen